[Musique]
avec martine moreau qui est coprésidente
des entrepreneurs heureuse en bourgogne
franche comté qu'est ce que c'est que
les entrepreneurs aux martin alors c'est
des entrepreneuses active et c'est
surtout des entrepreneurs heureuse les
entrepreneuses heureuse parce que quand
on entreprend famille quand on
entreprend sa nouvelle carrière
si on n'est pas heureuse ça va pas le
faire à quoi ont connu une entrepreneuse
ou une entrepreneure heureuse parce que
moi je connais les motards on sait
qu'ils ont des moustiques collées sur
les dettes parce que voilà ils sont
aussi c'est pas pareil
expliquez moi à quoi on reconnaît que
qu'une femme est heureuse dans une
entreprise et en direction d'entreprise
notamment quand elle a envie de se lever
le matin pour aller travailler déjà je
passais déjà une première chose qui
montre qu'elle est heureuse quand elle
continue sa vie professionnelle avec
plaisir et quand elle partage c'est
justement le but des entrepreneuses 7
partager ses compétences et en vis à vis
et sans sourire avec tout le monde
bon tout le monde sourit ce matin donc
si vous êtes heureuse dans votre boulot
ça transpire en tout cas ça c'est bien
beau synatel valérie pas très bien bon
l'entrepreneuriat au féminin ça donne
quoi
voilà quelques images et puis juste
après vous pour intervenir et poser des
questions sur l'entrepreneuriat au
féminin regarder fo dire comment femmes
entrepreneuses aux femmes entrepreneurs
comme tu veux mais ça ne m'empêchera pas
d'être entreprenante en france question
entrepreneuriat on est encore loin de la
parité si quatre créateurs d'entreprise
sur dix sont des femmes les femmes ne
représentent que 14% des dirigeants
d'entreprises de plus de 10 salariés
barrière psychologique difficulté à
concilier vie professionnelle et vie de
famille
machisme manque de soutien les obstacles
ne manquent hélas pas
du coup 65 % des femmes qui veulent
devenir entrepreneurs ont la peur de
l'échec contre 54 % des hommes en
diplômés de l'enseignement supérieur
neuf fois sur dix et ex salariés à 60 %
les femmes se lancent dans la création
d'entreprise autour de 35 ans et
lorsqu'elle monte leur boîte les
patronnes sont encore cantonnée à
certains secteurs spécifiques comme la
santé humaine et l'action sociale les
services à la personne où l'enseignement
les femmes sont encore peu nombreuses
dans la création de start up et le
secteur de l'ateq autres grosses
qualités
la patronne se trouvent surtout dans les
tpe les très petites entreprises et se
fait rare dans celles de plus de 1000
salariés seulement 7 5% de femmes
mais attention la génération des moins
de 30 ans risquent de changer la donne
38% des jeunes femmes rêvent de monter
leur boîte vous adoriez dire merci
patron
vous adorerez dire merci patronne alors
j'ai au moins une patronne la martine
moreau votre avis sur ce qu'on vient de
voir
c'est vrai que les femmes sont souvent
dans les tpe pme ça vient quand il
achète du temps pour que les entreprises
petites et moyennes entreprises pour le
thème ça change un peu mais nous dans
les entrepreneurs c'est vrai qu'on a
beaucoup de femmes qui sont seuls ou qui
développe petit à petit leur entreprise
et quand elles développent elles sortent
un petit peu du réseau ce que c'est plus
leurs yeux ils n'ont plus le temps de
partager avec nous quoi souvent donc on
va remonter cette association bourgogne
franche comté les entrepreneurs aux
parce que les femmes ont besoin de
sortir de leur bail leur solitude
justement elles sont souvent tout seul
quand elles entreprennent
elles ont peut-être quitter une vie
salariale pour devenir entrepreneuse et
ne savent pas toujours où s'adresser
trouver les réseaux donc on a créé sur
les os pour partager pour faire du
réseautage
heureusement martine moreau ça veut dire
que selon vous les femmes n'auraient pas
les mêmes problèmes que les hommes dans
l'entreprise
on n'a pas les mêmes problèmes on est
différente
je vous en vos derniers retranchements
est-ce que j'ai enfin contre moi
j'en suis convaincu non mais on a les
mêmes problèmes en entreprise mais par
contre partagé la vie personnelle et
professionnelle
même si les hommes disent qu'ils
partagent c'est quand même un peu le
rôle de la femme mais au manager on a à
gérer la vie perso la vie
professionnelle
et c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
on n'a pas les mêmes problématiques les
mêmes questionnements quand même je vois
les seuls qui accueillait ce parce que
vous êtes aussi une toute jeune maman on
verra plus tard que vous travaillez en
couple dans un des restaurants bernard
loiseau où vous êtes chef pâtissière
donc effectivement tout mais l'effet que
c'est pas forcément évident à lui
préféré c'est sûr c'est sûr que même
depuis le début que j'ai commencé dans
la restauration on voit directement le
fossé qu'il ya entre les hommes et les
femmes
on a besoin de se faire une place on a
besoin de montrer qu'on est là qu'on
s'est fait autant que même si à la base
on a les mêmes compétences en fait on
est obligé de montrer qu'on peut faire
aussi bien
et puis on va alors moi j'avoue que j'ai
eu beaucoup de chance dans mon parcours
j'ai beaucoup de personnes assez assez
ouverte assez compréhensive j'ai
rencontré beaucoup de gens qui m'ont
aidé mais je sais qu'on a plein qui ont
dit on vous allez on cuisine en jeu ça
change mais pas tant que ça il y en a
tellement encore qui sont machos folie
oui voilà la maison est le plus dans mon
métier voilà on a beaucoup beaucoup de
oui la cuisine c'est pas facile même
pour vous avoir serré la main tout à
l'heure j'ai compris que vous ne vous
laissez pas faire
en cuisine une sacrée poigne poigne
aussi pour vous valérie poste parce que
finalement c'est un peu le même scénario
que vos camarades de jeu vaut si vous
avez une vie professionnelle et vie
personnelle
oui c'est vrai je pense que quel que
soit le secteur d'activité on a tous
besoin effectivement de faire sa place
et de trouver une légitimité et le
regard général va être un petit peu plus
exigeants je tairai sur une femme que
sur un homme et il ya besoin
effectivement de montrer que nous sommes
aussi légitime et que les compétences
sont qui présente également chez les
femmes allaient topal interactions je
suis pas en force ce matin donc 0 805
383 383 bonjour comment vous
appelez-vous et quel est votre question
s'il vous plaît bonjour je m'appelle
juliette je suis en cours de création
d'une entreprise dédiée à
l'entrepreneuriat féminin
et je me posais la question suivante
existe-t-il des aides spécifiques
fiscales financières ou autres dédiés
aux femmes créatrices d'entreprise
merci merci à vous juliette alors des
aides fiscales financières martine
moreau il en existe qu elle pas
forcément mais il faut s'adresser aussi
aux droits de la femme qui nous soutient
régulièrement ses mystères des droits de
la femme avec les délégués aux droits
des femmes qui sont sur dijon sur la
saône et loire et par tout en bourgogne
franche comté
voilà c'est ce genre dette qu'on peut
trouver
et puis à les aides à la création
d'entreprise mais qui sont pas
spécialement pour les femmes par contre
en accompagnement des accusateurs qui
permettent d'accompagner les femmes et
de leur donner un peu plus de visibilité
par rapport à ces organismes
alors soyons concrets et pratiques
martine moreau comment vous les
accompagnez ces femmes ça se passe
comment j'adhère à cette association
les entrepreneurs oeil ça me coûte de
l'argent et vous me proposez quoi alors
ça coûte 30 euros par an voilà donc
c'est vraiment abordable c'est ce qu'on
a voulu abordable pour tous pour tout
sur tout oui et puis ils ont dit non
c'est 100% féminin d'accord ou alors
j'ai pas en kilt et mercor auteurs donc
concrètement que les personnes viennent
dans une matinale les matinales c'est le
vendredi matin sur dijon et c'est une
fois par mois sur chalon sur mac os sur
nevers et sur lons le saunier tunnel
parce que me nativel parce que au fond
dernière j'avais essayé de trouver le
vainqueur des petites astuces doké
matinale
c'est une un endroit où on boit café et
et tout ce qu'on veut et on a des
ateliers proposés en fonction de nos
compétences
donc les personnes viennent comme elles
veulent c'est gratuit au départ on peut
adhérer au bout de trois quatre matinées
l on adhère si on le veut mais on vient
voir déjà pour savoir si on a envie de
rejoindre ce réseau ou pas allez je vous
propose d'écouter le témoignage
d'aurélie au 0 805 383 380 en rose et
coups tordus profondément à l'entrée des
femmes dans le monde de
l'entrepreneuriat parce que je trouve
qu'il n'y en a pas encore assez et que
en tant que femmes nous pouvons apporter
beaucoup plus à ce monde des qualités
nouvelles comme une certaine qualité
dans pâti d' écoute de meilleures
relations aux autres
c'est une nouvelle énergie et finalement
à apporter et en plus nous avons besoin
de beaucoup plus de rôle modèle de
personnes a admis les deux femmes à
admirer femme entrepreneur agréé dans ce
monde donc nous en avons besoin
merci aurélie pour votre témoignage
aussi besoin de vos témoignages au 0 805
383 383 ou sur les matins de france 3
pour apprendre à la base d'ici quelques
secondes vous admirez vous une patronne
en particulier martine moreau il ya un
nom qui vous vient ce que moi par
exemple je pense tout de suite à à
christine lagarde avait quatre femmes
d'affaires femme politique actuelle
présidente de la banque centrale
européenne tout de suite moi je vous
pensez à une femme valérie prost par
exemple ont voulu s'il d'arroser femmes
patronat comme ça que vous admirez chez
moi je vais forcément le premier nom qui
me vient en tête c'est dominique loiseau
de la tron et elle a vécu tellement de
choses près la mort de son mari elle
s'est relevée elle a créé une entreprise
florissante florissante et qui se
développe aujourd'hui et elle reste
tellement tellement humaine tellement
abordables comme patronne que je peux
qu'espérer être un jour à sa place alors
vous vous êtes passé du rêve à la
réalité parce que vous travaillez dans
le groupe bernard loiseau on va y
revenir d'ici quelques minutes
mais qu'est ce que vous dites vous
martine moreau justement aux femmes que
vous rencontrez dans vos matinale ces
fameuses
ciné consacrée aux femmes au sein de
cette association d'être entrepreneur
heureuse quels conseils vous leur donnez
pour passer du rêve à la réalité alors
j'étais hier avec des femmes justement
dans l'incubateur qui s'appelle les
premières et où on accompagne les
personnes qui recherchent leurs voix on
veut dire et c'est surtout y croire il y
en avait une qui disait je vais rêver
mais j'ai pas le droit de rêver bas
c'est justement rêver son nouveau métier
rêvé sa nouvelle vie c'est super
important y croire et aller au bout de
ses rêves
je prends le corps donc oser changer de
vie aux échanges et de vie on a fait une
journée des entrepreneurs eux justement
sur toute une journée avec c'est quoi le
changement c'est quoi comment changer sa
vie aux échanges et sa vie osé se lancer
aux et mélanger la vie personnelle
professionnelle
comment faire quoi vous vous rencontrez
vous partager les compétences entre
voilà tout à fait on fait des ateliers
autour des compétences de chacune et
chacune amène son savoir et sans savoir
être savoir faire enfin ab ça nous on
aime pour encourager et soutenir la
création d'entreprise au féminin une
association de la région les
entrepreneurs heureuse aller faire un
petit tour sur le net pour essayer d'en
savoir beaucoup plus